with big data we've come to expect big
responsibility in order to handle the
complexity of today's data you need to
spend a lot on hardware plan ahead for
scalability and four hours into system
architecture picks no joke and this just
gets you up and running you still need
someone know a team to make sure
everything's running smoothly and even
after all that headache running queries
can still take anywhere from minutes to
hours and mistakes can be costly
wouldn't you rather focus on finding
insights from your data than developing
the infrastructure around it Google
bigquery is a fully managed data
warehouse that removes setup hassles and
runs queries rocket fast fast enough to
analyze terabytes of data in seconds
petabytes in minutes Google bigquery
works on a pay-as-you-go basis you only
pay for the bytes process
what if you have a really big query it's
simple
we'll spin up an entire data center to
quickly process it for you just sit back
and let us handle the scaling Google
bigquery encrypts replicates and deploys
your data across multiple data centers
for maximum durability and service
uptime with just a couple of clicks you
can control where you store your data
sharing and collaboration or easy as
well you decide who can access your data
and because you can use standard sequel
queries anyone can get involved Plus
bigquery integrates with Google cloud
platform products and other software so
you can readily load process and make
interactive visualizations of your data
it's never been easier to analyze
massive datasets and find insights fast
with Google bigquery head to cloud
google.com slash bigquery